wonder woman 1984 is packed with
surprises
action and emotion there's a lot going
on in this neon fairy tale so you might
not catch it all on your first viewing
here's the full story including the key
elements of the ending
obviously spoilers are ahead you've been
warned
some 70 years after the events of the
first wonder woman
diana lives in a luxurious condo in
washington d.c
she chooses to spend time alone after
losing her one true love
steve trevor in world war one her home
is decorated with pictures of steve
and diana chooses to eat dinner by
herself and avoid
human connection while working at the
smithsonian by day
lucky you it's like now one day has
passed
but diana still dons her armor and
stands up for what's right
even if it's only by going after
small-time crooks during a robbery at a
dc mall
four would-be artifact thieves are
mystified when a stunning woman clad in
red blue and gold
swings from the ceiling with her golden
lasso of truth
dumping them onto a police cruiser
before vanishing however she does allow
one person a few glimpses a little girl
who watches diana vanquish the robbers
in adoration
with diana giving the girl a quick wink
before disappearing to keep her identity
a secret
diana might prefer to be alone but she
ends up making a friend when the meek
awkward barbara minerva joins the
smithsonian staff as a gemologist
constantly tripping over her own feet
and too soft-spoken to stand up for
herself
barbara immediately idealizes everything
about diana who comes off as strong and
confident
after barbara shows diana some of the
artifacts she's studying
including a mysterious citrine stone
diana
agrees to go out for a drink after work
the two end up bonding with diana
praising barbara's sweet personality and
open nature
admitting that she prefers to close
herself off from the world
later that evening alone in a park
barbara is assaulted by a drunk man
but diana comes to a rescue rather than
raising questions about diana's apparent
super strength
the incident only makes barbara aspire
to be like diana
even more down on his luck would be oil
tycoon maxwell lord
first appears on television screens in
the mall where diana stops the robbery
as he tries to convince folks that they
can improve their lives with the help of
his company
black gold cooperative despite the
glossy feel of his ads
maxwell is broke and his top investor
simon stagg
is getting angry desperate to make money
and support
as well as impress his young son
alistair
maxwell seeks out a rather unorthodox
fix
when he hears about the stone that
barbara and diana have discovered
the dreamstone he sees a way out of his
predicament
he comes up with a plan to use the
dreamstone for his own gains
seducing barbara to gain access to the
artifact for himself before max takes
possession of the stone
both diana and barbara wish upon it
though neither of them quite understand
what they're doing
diana wishes that steve could still be
with her the next day at a smithsonian
gala
she's taken aback when she discovers
that steve living in someone else's body
has indeed returned meanwhile barbara
wishes for the confidence and power of
her new friend diana
and begins to see a change almost
immediately she's suddenly striding
around the smithsonian
in slinky outfits and attracting
attention from everyone around her
at a gala maxwell invites her into a
room alone
but it's all a ruse to steal the dream
stone maxwell takes his wish
a huge step further too becoming the
stone himself
so he can grant anybody's wishes as well
as his own
with this power maxwell can manipulate
the entire world
making deals with international figures
and causing complete chaos
all three wishers eventually realize
there's a huge downside to the dream
stone
it steals your life essence when you
make a wish diana might be happy with
steve by her side
but her powers are fading she's unable
to harness her strength or
properly wield the lasso of truth
barbara completely loses the humanity
that drew diana to her in the first
place
driven only by vengeance and a thirst
for more strength and influence
you've always had everything well people
like me have had nothing
to make matters worse barbara makes more
wishes on the stone
through maxwell turning herself into the
animalistic
hyper-strong cheetah maxwell fares worst
of all
as he continues to grant wishes and
emotionally manipulate the world so he
has power over everybody
even the president of the united states
his body begins to break down
his nose and ears stream blood his eyes
are red
his body is visibly wrecked despite
these negative effects
everyone even diana is loathed to let go
of their wishes even when they discover
that the stone was created by the god of
treachery and mischief himself
but the only way to return to normal is
to recant
diana and steve realize there's only one
thing she can do to regain her power and
bring down
maxwell and barbara recant her wish
after yet
another emotional goodbye a sobbing
diana takes her wish back
and steve shuffles off this mortal coil
once again
with her full powers returned diana
discovers maxwell's plan to use a u.s
military broadcast system to speak to
the entire world so he can grant wishes
and mass
diana in the full splendor of the
ancient golden amazonian armor of
hysteria
defeats cheetah electrocuting her to
turn her back into barbara
she then confronts maxwell she wraps the
lasso of truth around him and speaks to
the world over the broadcast system
begging everyone to recant their wishes
they do
stopping a nuclear war as a result diana
also
uses the lasso to show maxwell a vision
of his young son alistair
convincing him to return to his family
at the beginning of the movie
a much younger diana competes in a hyper
athletic sporting event
though she is the youngest competitor by
far diana immediately takes first place
but when she's knocked off her horse at
a crucial moment all seems lost
but diana finds a secret shortcut
putting her firmly back in first place
when she returns to the arena her aunt
antiope disqualifies her
saying she cheated diana protests but
antiope tells her that her victory can't
be achieved by dishonesty
stressing that truth is of the utmost
importance she tells diana
no true hero is born from lies and
remember
greatness is not what you think diana is
disappointed in the moment but she takes
those lessons about truth and honesty
with her
antiope's message of honesty proves
especially important by the end of
wonder woman 1984
through all three characters and their
dreamstone wishes it's clear diana
barbara and maxwell are all pretending
to be somebody they're not
the stone exposes their greatest flaws
even as it gives them their hearts
desire
though it seems to people like barbara
that diana has zero problems in her
perfect life
diana's unwillingness to engage with
anybody in the wake of losing steve
is a front for her loneliness and a
craving for human connection
barbara rather than finding confidence
within herself tries to steal diana's
meanwhile maxwell wants to appear
powerful at any cost
despite the fact that he's broke and his
business is failing in the end
whether they're giving up true love
finding their own confidence
or reuniting with family diana barbara
and maxwell
understand that the stone despite its
seductive wish-granting abilities
can't actually help them at all only
honesty and clarity can lead to true
greatness
you can't take shortcuts in the
aftermath of maxwell's hostile takeover
and a narrowly averted nuclear war
the world seems to return to normal by
the holiday season
back in dc and alone once more diana
watches families
spend time together at a christmas
village and even without steve in her
life
she seems at peace however the clearest
example of diana's personal progress
comes when she finds herself face to
face with the man whose body steve
inhabited during his recent turn on
earth
rather than closing herself off diana
lets herself open up to this stranger
complimenting the outfit we saw steve
try on earlier and giving him a warm
smile before they part ways
whether they'll meet again isn't clear
but what's important is that diana
who was once so committed to being alone
is willing to make human connections
once again
letting steve go once and for all and
living life on her own terms
she also harnesses some impressive
superpowers mastering flying through the
clouds with ease
in the aftermath of her experience with
the stone she's even more powerful
throughout the film the audience and
diana learn about asteria
an ancient amazonian who sacrificed
herself
and her strength to protect the maschira
from the prying eyes of men
during the flashback to diana's
childhood her mother
queen hippolyta soothes her distraught
daughter by showing her the golden
statue of asteria
and telling the story of the brave
warrior who saved the island
when the audience gets a brief glimpse
of asteria herself
the actor playing her looks familiar and
for good reason
as she's played by linda carter who
played wonder woman on the small screen
in the 1970s
in a post credits sequence it's revealed
that asteria
like diana secretly lives among
humankind whether carter appears in a
future wonder woman installment remains
to be seen
but no matter what it's fascinating to
learn that diana
isn't alone and potentially has an
incredibly powerful ally nearby
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the dc eu are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you